bien on change le plateau gilles carez
arrive président de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée jérôme tu peux
rester c'est une bonne idée
je voudrais d'abord vous présenter
évidemment d'abord véronique véronique
louwagie qui est disputé de l'ordre et
qui est membre la commission des
finances qui secrétaire national aux pme
jean philippe urbain qui est président
d'un groupe d'entreprises
jean philippe hubert fait partie de ces
gens comme karine charbonnier qui
étaient avec nous tout à l'heure
peut-être qui est encore là qui sont
patrons de deux pays
des entreprises de taille intermédiaire
s'est reconnue aujourd'hui c'est un
statut c'est pas des petites entreprises
c'est pas des pme c'est pas des cac 40
c'est si l'entreprise note aux
recherches sans arrêt le développement
dont on se dit en a plein en allemagne
il y en a pas assez en france c'est là
où se crée le coeur de la valeur ajoutée
française
et puis gilles carrez ce qui va arriver
et jérôme chartier qui fait l'ensemble
de la convention sur le plateau parce
que il a envie de se montrer
et il le fait pas mal alors je voudrais
je voudrais peut-être résumer les choses
le président parlera d'ici trois quarts
d'heure une heure je voudrais résumer un
tout petit peu les choses
à ce stade le premier temps c'est que
nous avons parlé avec christian
saint-etienne et tous nos interlocuteurs
de dépenses publiques
c'est très important de considérer que
c'est la priorité nous devons baisser
les dépenses publiques on essaie de
chiffrer
on chiffre à 100 milliards ces dépenses
publiques et en effet l'exercice
compliqué toujours qui est un exercice
dans lesquelles nous avons isolé
documenté montré là où la dépense
publique pouvait être réduite alors on
peut inventer beaucoup d'autres choses
on a essayé de bien montrer que j'avais
des poches de productivité au fond dans
la dépense publique d'abord sur la masse
salariale c'est-à-dire sur la fonction
publique moins de fonctionnaires mieux
rémunérés rémunéré différemment c'est
pas une stigmatisation de la fonction
publique comme on le lit quelquefois
c'est au contraire une fonction publique
moderniser on est fiers de nos
fonctionnaires et en même temps on a
besoin d'une fonction publique qui va
monter en gamme dans les responsabilités
dans un état et des collectivités
locales qui verront leur périmètre
d'intervention de plus en plus
concentrée sur sur l'essentiel
donc évidemment la masse salariale elle
doit réduire parce que il y aura moins
de fonctionnaires même si chacun peut en
fonction de son mérite de la qualité de
son travail gagnait mieux sa vie et plus
deuxième point c'est évidemment sur
l'ensemble du modèle social c'est un
modèle pour personne vu qu'il est
financé par les générations qui viennent
ça peut pas être un modèle
donc ce modèle social aujourd'hui
j'ouvre les guillemets il représente
près de 650 milliards d'euros quand on
compte à la fois la sécurité sociale et
puis l'ensemble des prélève des
prestations sociales au sens très large
du terme
et tout cela évidemment doit être mieux
calibrée pour une pour un modèle social
plus juste parce qu'il est aujourd'hui
injuste puisqu'il crée du chômage et que
beaucoup de gens sont insatisfaits de ce
modèle social considèrent qu'ils n'ont
pas assez pour vivre
donc il doit être plus juste il doit
être plus efficient
il doit être plus efficace et doit pas
tirer la france vers le bas par le biais
de sommes tout à fait faramineuses et
l'état providence ne doit pas tuer au
fond l'état performance l'état qui
gagnent de l'argent l'état qui aide les
entreprises à travailler
donc ça c'est un point très important et
on permet de faire plus de 50 milliards
d'économies
grosso modo 8% de ce modèle social que
nous révisions en termes d'économie et
puis y'a les économies de productivité
beaucoup d'autres j'ai connu ça c'était
le thème de la première table ronde
givrée montrer qu'il est possible
aujourd'hui en france de réduire de 100
milliards la dépense publique le
deuxième temps c'est de se dire on doit
évidemment réduire la fiscalité et on
doit le faire en même temps
parce que si vous faites la réduction la
fiscalité deux ans après vous aurez
perdu beaucoup de temps et le signe que
vous lui signalant tout cas que vous
enverrez aux différents acteurs de
l'économie
si au fond toujours pareil les
prélèvements obligatoires sur les plus
élevés d'europe quand on regarde
catégorie par catégorie certains de nos
amis sur 7 sur cette tribune montré très
bien dit on est les champions du monde
dans pas mal de sujets je préférerais
qu'on soit les champions du monde de la
croissance
je préférerais qu'on soit les
championnats du monde champion du monde
de l'emploi
je préférerais qu'on soit les champions
du monde des finances publiques cher
gilles carez
en réalité on est champion du monde de
la fiscalité la dépense publique pour
arrêter évidemment avec ce mécanisme
absolument infernal qui conduit au
chômage la france au fonds par ses
politiques publiques choisies le chômage
il ya une préférence public pour le
chômage contre la valeur ajoutée contre
l'aide aux entreprises contre la qualité
la production en france
donc nous aurions deux temps de baisse
de la fiscalité un premier temps
concentrées sur les charges patronales
avec une réforme du cic eu avec avec
évidemment aussi une une réduction des
charges au niveau du travail non
qualifié c'est là où se situe beaucoup
des poches de deux créations d'emplois
en fait en tout cas d'embauché
on le voit bien beaucoup d'économistes
l'on dit long écrit de façon extrêmement
pertinentes et puis en même temps
évidemment une fin de l' isf ça a été
évoqué par ce que l'usf et un contre
productif a normalement présents dans
une fiscalité européenne qui évidemment
n'existe ça n'existe nulle part ailleurs
et puis une baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu parce que les catégories moyennes
on était considérablement taxer et qu'il
faut rendre aux catégories moyennes pour
redonner du souffle à la population
française
et puis un deuxième temps qui doit venir
et ce deuxième temps c'est aussi le
sujet de notre table ronde ce deuxième
temps il doit aller plus loin
il doit remettre decker la fiscalité sur
le capital ça a déjà été évoquée je
voudrais qu'on y revienne
la fiscalité sur le capital elle est
aujourd'hui trop forte
alors je suis bien que le mot capitale
il n'est pas très politiquement correct
ça fait capitaliste donc en france on
n'aime pas trop au fond simplement sans
capital n'y a pas d'emploi et s'il n'y a
pas une intensité capitalistique il peut
y avoir une intensité du travail s'il ya
pas de capital ça marche pas notamment
dans un pays
évidemment comme le nôtre c'est-à-dire
très développés où il faut de plus en
plus investir ça veut dire mettre de
plus en plus de capital pour tirer de
plus en plus de valeur ajoutée
comment peut-on innover sans capital
donc il faut évident qui est du capital
le capital c'est le fruit de l'epargne
c'est le fruit de l'épargné c'est mieux
comme nova
ban politiquement c'est mieux c'est plus
acceptable donc on doit réformer la
fiscalité sur les parcs on l'évoquera on
doit réformer la fiscalité aussi sur les
plus values on est plus values notamment
immobilière l'argent doit circuler et on
voit bien que les plus values
immobilières qui ont été montées à un
niveau très très élevés doivent être
réduites et on pense que les temps qui
ont été choisis sont des temps et
d'ailleurs ni à contribuer et donc nous
devons aujourd'hui revenir à des
périodes de temps d'annulation de ces
plus values qui soit plus raisonnable
pour les résidences et pour l'immobilier
puis une complexité énorme c'est à dire
que c'est pas les mêmes temps pour
l'impôt sur le revenu et pour les
prélèvements sociaux
voilà un certain nombre d'idées qui
s'ajoutent à une poursuite de la baisse
de l'impôt sur les sociétés alors pour
aller plus loin on ira plus loin après
juillet 2010 7 juin 2017 ont fait un
texte global dans lequel on évoque à la
fois la baisse de la fiscalité sur ces
deux temps on précise où on pressent
précise comment et puis la baisse des
dépenses
je voulais revenir sur deux points avant
de céder la parole à mes collègues
le premier point c'est sur le
financement du de la protection sociale
karine charbonnier l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure très bien c'est qu'il faut de
plus en plus essayer ça va être long ça
va être compliqué mais on le fait d'ores
et déjà au fond dans nos propositions
il va falloir délier le financement de
la protection sociale au fur et à mesure
du coût du travail le travail ne peut
pas financer l'ensemble de notre
protection sociale finance pas
d'ailleurs déjà l'ensemble aujourd'hui
mais ils financent une grande partie et
on voit bien qu'il ya souvent assez peu
de rapports entre le travail et le
financement de la protection sociale
donc il faut arrêter un principe qui au
fur et à mesure du temps délié ce lien
sorte de lien mythique entre le travail
et le financement de notre protection
sociale
en ce qui concerne les la réforme
fiscale
je le disais au début mais je voudrais y
revenir c'est une s'est pas uniquement
une
une réduction de la fiscalité que nous
proposons c'est une réforme de la
fiscalité
bien sûr on la réduit au passage mais
c'est une réforme on considère qu' il ya
des impôts qu'il ne faut pas toucher
il ya des impôts qu'il faut supprimer
l'isf ou là la myriade de petites taxes
qui ont été évoqués tout à l'heure sur
la production qu'il faut au fur et à
mesure du temps élaguer qui ne rapporte
rien donc l'impôt qui ne rapporte rien
mais il faut mieux le supprimer parce
qu'au fond il rapporte quand même
toujours un peu et quand il rapporte un
peu il est indûment pris dans la poche
de ceux qui le payent et puis il faut
considérer que c'est transfert de
fiscalité à lier une réduction de la
fiscalité d'une réforme profonde de
notre système fiscal
enfin sur le prélèvement à la source a
été évoquée moi je suis assez favorable
à l'idée que il faut réduire ce décalage
la vérité c'est qu'on se trompe de sujet
bien sûr il faut réduire ce décalage au
maximum si on peut payer l'impôt de
l'année pendant l'année sur les revenus
de l'année tant mieux parce que ça
réduit l'incertitude et les acteurs
économiques comme les ménages ils ont
besoin d'une réduction de la certitude
et sur l'impôt sur le revenu c'est très
important de ne pas avoir au fond au 1er
janvier une sorte de 2,2 de dettes
vis-à-vis de l'état sur des revenus qui
ont été perçus et qui n'ont pas encore
été tech c'est donc plutôt que de faire
comme les socialistes la retenue à la
source pourquoi la source ce n'est pas
l'intérêt d'autant plus qu'à ce moment
là vous mettez à contribution les
entreprises
combien d'autres choses à faire il faut
réduire ce décalage
l'administration fiscale doit le faire
on a une administration fiscale moderne
on est autant du numérique on est autant
d des big data
donc il n'ya pas de raison particulière
qu une information qui est dans une
entreprise ne peut pas être transmises
en temps un peu plus réelle qu'au xxème
siècle à l'administration fiscale qui
peut peut-être avec un mois ou deux mois
de décalage vous mensualisés bien sûr
vous mensualisés mais vous mensualisés
sur des revenus perçus dans l'année ça
résoudrait définitivement le problème du
décalage et ça n'aurait pas évidemment
cette idée d'une retenue à la source qui
baissent considérablement votre feuille
de paye et en plus c'est perçu par les
entreprises qui ont bien d'autres choses
affaire voilà ce que je souhaitais dire
on dirait un mot de la tva mais pour
tout à l'heure je vais céder la parole
tout de suite à jean philippe urbain
parce que les oatei croule sous les
charges elles ont des problèmes de
transmission bien évidemment et on
aimerait bien avoir l'opinion d'un
patron de tei sur ces sujets merci mon
cher eric moi je vais vous raconter
comme une histoire sympathique parce que
c'est la mienne et que je ne suis pas en
train de me plaindre en permanence de
tout moi je trouve que ma vie
personnelle est assez marrante
j'étais salarié dans une banque était
directeur de la banque
et puis un jour je me suis ma banque a
été nationalisée alors je me suis dit
qu'est ce que je vais faire je vais
rester fonctionnaires dans cette banque
nationalisée
c'était en 1981 et non j'ai décidé non
je vais devenir chef d'entreprise
i dans un
pays qui s'appelle marolles des cinq
années où il ya 400 habitants où
j'emploie 120 personnes pas mal bon oui
c'est des coups et ruraux dans lequel on
est et on emploie des gens dans des
coins comme ça voilà alors ça c'est pour
faire le parcours mon parcours personnel
ce qui est intéressant dans ce parcours
c'est que j'ai été directeur de banque
d'une part et d'autre part celle
entreprise quand j'étais directeur de
banque qu'on m'a dit il faut respecter
les consignes de la banque de france
j'ai dit ça c'est vrai alors les
consignes la banque de france sont très
claires quand on est dans une entreprise
il faut qu'on ait des fonds propres
parce que sinon on a une mauvaise
cotation banque de france et si on a une
mauvaise cotation de banque de france a
demandé mort parce qu'on leur a jamais
des crédits et toutes les banques et
viendront vous dire monsieur on peut pas
vous faire crédit parce que etc
mais en réalité c'est parce que vous
avez une mauvaise cotation banque de
france il faut donc avoir une bonne
cotation pour avoir une bonne cotation
faut voir les fonds propres voire des
fonds propres il faut accumuler les
résultats dans la société jusqu'à plus
soif
c'est ce que j'ai fait pendant trente
ans on a accumulé nos résultats dans la
société
on est parti dans la pme de base que
j'avais acheté un million 1 mais avec un
million de fonds propres on a maintenant
60 millions de fonds propres
alors là j'ai l'accord de la banque de
france ils sont d'accord ils me verse un
bonne cotation il me donne une bonne
cotation et me disent vous êtes trois
plus vous êtes un type sympathique très
bien qu'à ce moment-là l'administration
fiscale est derrière mais c'est comme
docteur jekyll et mister hyde
vous avez docteur jekyll qui est la
banque de france qui vous dis bravo
monsieur urbain vous êtes vraiment un
type sympathique si vous avez le fils
qui vous dit vous êtes un gros
de capitalistes parce que en accumulant
des fonds propres
vous avez fait une chose terrible vous
avez accumulé du capital ah bah oui
monsieur oui ça le fonds propres c'est
l'autre nom du capital il ya les pagnes
il ya le fonds propres et puis au total
ça fait le capital voilà alors je suis
un horrible les grands capitalistes
puisque vous avez 60 millions de fonds
propres
donc si jamais ça vous arrive ne faites
pas comme j'ai fait moins parce que
essayer de passer à travers la banque de
france d'essayer de vous débrouiller
sans la banque de france sans la
cotation montbleu france vous y
arriverez pas mais enfin vous pouvez
toujours essayer parce que à la fin
l'administration fiscale lui c'est
docteur jekyll et mister hyde
donc je ne sais plus lequel une méchante
lequel est gentiment fin l'admiration
fiscale ce sont les méchants et vous
empêche de vivre alors ils vous
empêchent de constituer des fonds
propres
ils vous font payer un impôt énorme au
niveau de la dea on l'a dit tout à
l'heure ne pas le répéter ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que le total des
impôts que je paye un impôt sur les
productions et à l'impôt sur les
sociétés c'est 50% de mon résultat brut
c'est pas du tout 33 % donc je paye
d'abord 50% si je comparais qu'un
allemand lui paye 25%
donc moi je vais payer le double de
l'allemand c'est simple à comprendre
alors c'est pour ça madame que du côté
de pontarlier vous avez des centaines de
bagnols qui descendent vers vallorbe et
vous en rêvez strictement aucune qui
remonte de la suisse voilà c'est comme
ça que ça se passe et est donc les
allemands sont grosso modo à moitié de
ils vont deux fois plus vite que moi
pour accumuler du capital comme moi je
gagne sans eux ils peuvent accumuler ou
me gagne sans moi j'accumule 50 et il
accumule 75
voilà c'est une différence énorme
deuxième chose une fois que vous avez
accumulé du capital il faut quand même
aussi voir que de temps en temps on peut
avoir un souci c'est le problème de la
transmission
alors moi j'ai trois enfants donc en a
deux qui sont rentrés dans la boîte
c'est bien ils vont leur prendre tant
mieux eux ils ont un régime fiscal
favorable
c'est le la plaque dutreil niches
fiscales existent mais alors la
troisième elle ait pas de fait une
erreur
fallait pas qu'elle qu'elle veuille est
indépendante par rapport à ses deux
frères il faut qu'elle travaille avec
eux obligatoirement parce que sinon eh
bien elle va payer un impôt sur le
capital
alors le problème c'est qu'elle n'a pas
le capital elle va avoir un impôt de
transmission le var la peau de
succession mais elle n'a pas pascal à 26
ans n'a rien du tout d'ailleurs
alors le résultat c'est que il faut
premièrement qu'elle paye en isf l'a
d'ores et déjà parce que je lui ai
transmis 16,66 % alors elle ou avoir un
isf
et puis deuxièmement il faut caler
également après alabau succession ça
quand je vais crever là j'espère que ce
sera le plus tard possible variable pour
le moment c'est quand même elle qui va
le finir par le payer alors le résultat
c'est que qu'est ce que ça veut dire qui
va le payer puisqu'elle n'a pas de
capital mais ça m d'entreprise alors
l'entreprise
il faut d'abord premièrement que pour
être payé son isf faut que je dise très
un dividende si à latran à la 30000
euros de dons isf à payer sur son
entreprise
vous avez quelques calculs elle à 20% de
60 millions parce que l'état considère
que les 60 millions c'est ma richesse à
moi donc c'est la sienne aussi c'est
évidemment faux c'est la richesse de mon
entreprise mais c'est pas grave
l'entreprise et dans ce cas là c'est la
même chose - et mon entreprise c'est
pareil donc j'ai d'abord un impôt à
payer
alain à papier sur lui c'est pour payer
ce qu'elle doit payer
je dois me je dois prendre sur les
résultats bruts 2,6 fois plus alors
monsieur caresse vous avez vous pouvez
le calcul de votre côté mais si vous
voulez je peux vous le donner il faut
payer 2,5 fois plus vite 2 6 fois plus
de prendre sur mon résultat brut de mon
entreprise pour que ma fille puisse
payer son isf
alors qu'elle a déjà le barème de la loi
dutreil après à l'impôt sur les
successions si jamais ça nous arrive ça
veut dire qu'elle aura à payer 11,5 x
11,5 pour cent à 25% du capital en
question des fonds propres en question à
l'administration fiscale pour payer 6,5
il va falloir que mais ses frères et
soeurs paye 29 % prennent 29% de des
fonds propres de l'entreprise
comment voulez vous que ça marche en
france alors que vous êtes en a mais en
angleterre en amérique en allemagne en
italie ça n'existe pas le résultat c'est
que nous avons 4500 ati en france madame
charbonnier effectivement est un bon
exemple plus célèbre que moi parce
qu'elle est passée à la télé elle a été
formidable ce jour là et on l'a félicité
la remercie encore
et moi c'est pareil on est au total 4500
le problème c'est que il ya 3000
entreprises françaises par éthique qui
contribuent à la richesse nationale de
façon plus active que la moyenne nous
sommes dans celle là le problème c'est
quand l'allemagne on à 12500 udi en en
italie il y en a dix mille en angleterre
il y en a onze mille et nous on est
quatre mille cinq cents mais pourquoi
mais parce que je viens de vous raconter
toute l'histoire parce que on nous
empêche de constituer nos fonds propres
on nous dès qu'on en a en nous les
piques on nous fait payer des impôts
alors que on n'a aucune raison de les
payer parce que
ma pauvre fille n'a aucun dividende de
la société parce que précisément mes
enfants continue à faire ce que je leur
ai appris pendant 35 ans envie de son
salaire et ses dividendes on les
accumule
on ne distribue pas et on les accumule
dans l'entreprise et le résultat final
c'est que il faut que ce soit moi qui
lui paye son isf parce qu'en fait sinon
elle elle serait furieuse contre sept
frères et soeurs et le résultat c'est
que vous créiez une bisbille dans les
familles
et si vous créez une bisbille dans les
familles qu'est ce qui va se passer le
fils va être ravie parce qu'on va vendre
l'entreprise et une fois qu'on leur a
vendu l'entreprise
les banques d'affaires vont être
enchantés de vendre l'entreprise les
parce que ça fera des commissions et les
l'office absolument chanter parce que là
il va peu il va prendre l'impôt sur les
plus values
alors là ils vont en prendre plein plein
plein ça à faire 35 % des fonds prend
pas question donc on ne peut pas
continuer à vivre avec des impôts de ce
type de cette nature alors on me dira
vous travaillerez si vous faites ça vous
ne travailler que pour les entrepreneurs
et moi je dis il faut travailler aussi
pour les entreprenants parce que nous
avons nous sommes des gaullistes nous
avons la chance de pouvoir dire que nous
avons nous inventer la participation je
vais vous raconter une dernière petite
anecdote j'ai une usine en belgique
j'ai fait de la participation en
belgique
j'ai donc réuni les syndicats et j'ai
dit je vais vous faire de la
participation et je vais vous donner 20
% de mon résultat parce que là bas si on
la loi de faire ce qu'on veut mais ya
pas de participation légal donc j'ai dit
je voudrais 20% du résultat alors la
fille qui représente le syndicat c'est
en flandre mardi mais non monsieur ben
toi tu es tu es socialiste 1 j'ai dit
non je ne suis pas socialiste je suis
gaulliste
ouais c'est quoi ça gaulliste à et bien
le fait est que il faut qu'on est là il
faut développer la participation est de
penser qu'on a taxé à 20 % la
participation de mes ouvriers alors nous
on avait fait 8 et après les socialistes
sont passés de 8 à 20 franchement il
faut arrêter ça la participation c'était
hors impôts il faut que ça reste hors
impôt alors vivre une grande politique
pour le capital et vivent une grande
politique pour la participation
pendant que vous voyez les hôtes et ne
manque pas de souffle mais c'est pas si
simple que ça et ça nécessite des
réformes en profondeur jean-philippe la
très très bien dit et on proposera ses
réformes
véronique veux-tu prolonger les propos
de philippe urbain comme secrétaires
nationales aux pme sur les successions
choses pas lève mans libératoire sur la
fiscalité de l'épargné je crois que la
transmission d des entreprises c'est
c'est un vrai défi quelques chiffres qui
sont les nôtres aujourd'hui ses 60 mille
entreprises qui sont proposés à la vente
chaque année et seulement trente mille
sont vendus c'est à dire une déperdition
importante
derrière c'est un panel de 175000
entreprise qui compte tenu de l'âge des
chefs d'entreprises de la situation des
entreprises serait à vendre
voyez donc quelque chose de très
important et on chiffres dans les dix
années à venir le nombre d'entreprises
qui pourraient être transmises à 750
milles
beaucoup d'entreprises ne réussissent
pas la leur transmission est derrière
quand une entreprise n'est pas transmise
c'est treize salariés qui se trouvent au
chômage ont certes c'est une moyenne
mais derrière c'est un vrai impact sur
l'emploi
alors on a différentes natures au niveau
des transmissions d'entreprises
certaines se passe plutôt bien
sont les entreprises viables d'une bonne
taille ou là les transmissions ont lieu
mais derrière on a les pme ou là on a
une vraie difficulté et les modalités
aussi de transmission d'un certain
nombre de grandes entreprises
on a vu pour des grandes entreprises se
développer sur les années précédentes
des systèmes de fusions acquisitions
avec des
le bo derrière avec des financeurs
institutionnels et internationaux et
tout ça contribue je dirais à pomper
dans l'entreprise les ressources et
quand les entreprises n'ont plus les
ressources derrière ce sont des
investissements au moins c'est de
l'innovation en moins alors le premier
élément sur lequel il faut effectivement
intervenir c'est le coup ça a été évoqué
au travers l'exemple
il nous a été présentée préalablement le
coût de la transmission en france il est
énorme
le coût de la transmission il est évalué
entre 5 à 11 % et là je ne parle pas des
impôts type isf comme vous évoquez
simplement le coût de la succession ou
le coût de la transmission sur la valeur
de l'entreprise un moment donné et dans
les autres pays on a des situations très
différentes en allemagne au royaume uni
en italie
ce coût est nulle ou envoyez-nous d'un
côté 5 à 11 % et sur ces trois pays que
je viens de citer nul
d'autres pays ont des taux moindres
c'est le cas des pays bas on est à 3% la
3,39 exactement la belgique 3 %
l'espagne 0,02 pour cent c'est dire que
quasiment nul
voilà donc en france on a une vraie
situation à ce niveau là où le coût pèse
et lorsqu'il y a un coût effectivement
il faut que l'entreprise distribue des
dividendes
aucune entreprise garde du résultat pour
payer ce coup et tout ce résultat tous
ses dividendes
ce sont autant de ressources qui ne sont
pas affectés à l'investissement
industriel à l'investissement productif
dans les années qui viennent donc une
vraie réflexion il nous faut
effectivement sur les droits de
succession pouvoir intervenir parce que
les entreprises françaises ont cette
particularité d'être relativement
important au niveau des pme familiales
nos pme c'est 83 % de notre tissu dont
les il faut absolument intervenir sur
les droits de succession
nous avions un abattement qui avaient
été diminuées à 100000 euros
l'objectif c'est de revenir sur cet
abattement avec un abattement qui serait
portée à 160000 euros donc un soutien
important avec des abattements pour tout
ce qui est transmission familiale je
crois que c'est quelque chose de très
très important le deuxième point aussi
ça a été évoqué sur la table
pressez précédente c'est une stabilité
je crois qu'il faut apporter de la
stabilité à la fois pour les
cessionnaires qui réfléchissent à leur
transmission à leur cession derrière on
a toute la fiscalité du patrimoine
parce que dans le cadre des
transmissions un grand nombre de
transmissions sont en parallèle avec des
départs à la retraite de chef
d'entreprise c'est ce que vous évoquez
avec derrière une organisation de
fiscalité du patrimoine aussi et là
effectivement il ya une vraie réflexion
avec tout ce qui est prélèvement
libératoire qui doit être prise en
compte
derrière on a une simplicité qui le faut
mettre en oeuvre d'évoquer le pacte
dutreil qui a été un élément de soutien
important formidable qui a rendu service
à des tas de transmission familiale sur
notre territoire mais il faut continuer
à simplifier ce pacte dutreil
il ya des demandes régulières que
revienne sur tout ce qui est déclaration
annuelle des signataires du pacte chaque
année voilà un certain nombre de points
à prendre en compte pour simplifier tout
ce qui est transmission d'entreprise &
beauty qui sont à la disposition des
chefs d'entreprise on a un autre point
également qui est le recours au crédit
pour les cessionnaires vous qu'à un
moment donné quand on achète une
entreprise il faut avoir recours au
crédit
et là c'est vrai qu'on ait une vraie
difficulté au niveau des organismes
financiers
vous évoquez la difficulté de cotation
banque de france durant la vie d'une
entreprise
là ça peut être le cas aussi au moment
de la la cession au moment de la
transmission une difficulté ce niveau là
et là on doit avoir bpi france qui doit
être un rôle qui doit être être un
levier
il faut véritablement se battre pour que
bpi france intervienne sur les failles
de marché ça c'est absolument essentiel
bpi france n'est pas une banque comme
les autres elle ne doit pas être une
banque comme les hôtels doit absolument
intervenir sur les failles de marché
elle ne doit pas intervenir en
concurrence avec les autres organismes
financiers qui eux interviennent de
manière complètement complètement
différente
voilà un certain nombre de points au
niveau de la transmission des
entreprises
un dernier chiffre pour dire qu' on doit
véritablement avoir une politique
publique sur la transmission des
entreprises parce qu'en france nous
avons des transmissions à des taux très
inférieur à ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays 14% de transmission
d'entreprises en france quand ses 59 %
en allemagne 70 % en italie donc on doit
avoir une vraie interrogation et c'est
par la transmission des entreprises que
nous arrivons à avoir que nous
arriverons avoir désobéi pour dépasser
la situation qui peut exister de
différence notamment avec avec
l'allemagne voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur
un certain nombre de freins à prendre en
compte
j'irai le coût de la transmission avec
tout ce qui est droit de succession et
prélèvement libératoire simplification
stabilité également l'aide sur le crédit
pour les cessionnaires des des
entreprises parce que là aussi c'est un
vrai enjeu et je rajouterais que sur
cette partie une réflexion qui doit
conduire à flécher tout ce qui est
épargné des particuliers vers les
entreprises parce que là aussi un vrai
sujet on à 1500 milliards d'euros
d'assurances vie aujourd'hui
et là il devrait il faut que nous
réfléchissions à ce qu'il y ait un
fléchage vers tout ce qui concerne les
entreprises o'neill la mise en place du
pea pme qui a été créé il y à quelques
temps mais derrière le pays aux pme on
sait qu'on en a un certain nombre 80
milles qui ont été créés mais derrière
on a trois mille euros d'epargne en
moyenne sur ces pme c'est à dire si le
dispositif est suscité l'intérêt et on
le voit par le nombre de pays europe pme
qui ont été créés et derrière on voit
que ça ne fonctionne pas parce que 3000
euros de moyenne sur un pee à pme sais
rien alors ce alors que le plafond et
80000 euros donc une vraie réflexion
également pour inciter un fléchage de
l'épargné des particuliers vers les
entreprises
hélas il y à une manne voilà donc un
vrai enjeu sur la transmission des
entreprises
merci beaucoup merci merci à véronique
c'était très précis et très très très
utile juge je disais tout à l'heure en
commençant mais on était moins nombreux
il ya vraiment une valve assure
fiscalisation la sueur administration
n'assure normalisation ça conduit notre
pays à une sous compétitivité et on voit
bien que ça se niche sans jeu de mots
sur beaucoup de sujets que ça nécessite
des réformes en profondeur tant du
volume de dépenses publiques et donc une
réforme des politiques publiques et en
même temps évidemment une réduction et
une réforme de notre fiscalité ce qui a
été dit par véronique commun par jean
philippe huelin sur la transmission est
une vraie question
on vit de plus en plus longtemps donc on
doit travailler plus en plus longtemps
on propose dans les réductions de
dépenses publiques évidemment un
allongement de l'âge de la retraite mais
en même temps on voit bien qu'il faut
transmettre car le bon argent c'est un
argent qui circulent dans l'économie qui
irrigue l'économie si l'argent ne
circule pas il ne règle rien on
n'investit plus au fond on est sur un
matelas et on devient des rentiers une
l'économie de rente n'est pas évidemment
l'objectif pour une france qui se
redresse et la transmission d'entreprise
doit être privilégiée au moment de la
transmission d'entreprise il doit pas y
avoir appauvrissement l'entreprise
s'il ya un appauvrissement l'entreprise
ya affaiblissement de l'entreprise et
donc affaiblissement de l'emploi en
france et donc affaiblissement la france
et même chose pour les particuliers il
ya un moment donné vous vivez plus
longtemps vous avez envie de transmettre
à vos enfants
on doit pouvoir le feu nous le faisions
à une époque ça a été considérablement
réduits il faut refaire circuler cet
argent entre les générations sinon ça ne
peut pas fonctionner voilà je voudrais
peut-être c'est dès maintenant la parole
à jérôme chartier qui va nous parler
d'un sujet qu'il choisira lui-même
ça s'est super je vois parler de ce que
je veux alors voudrais vous parler
d'eric woerth est aussi de dépense
publique parce que on a beaucoup parlé
de ce qui est le plus populaire c'est à
dire la baisse des impôts bon il faut
aussi qu'on parle de ce qui est moins
populaire c'est la baisse de la dépense
on est d'accord sinon le travail
beaucoup trop facile et moi je voudrais
vous dire parce que je pense que
lorsqu'on parle de dépenses publiques
voyez c'est pas seulement se contenter d
qu'à faut qu'on ils font rentrer dans
les détails et en l'occurrence ces
détails c'est ce qu'on fait émond
l'occurrence ce que je fais avec valérie
pécresse à la région ile de france
depuis trois mois valérie m'a demandé
d'être le premier vice président de la
région et m'a dit de façon très précise
de s'atteler si vous voulez à une
réduction de la dépense alors on réduit
pas la dépense juste comme ça pour faire
plaisir on réduit la dépense pour deux
raisons la première et ça c'est vraiment
la première parce que je ne supporte pas
de dépenser de l'argent qui ne sert à
rien je sais pas comment vous êtes pour
vous mais moi j'estime que l'impôt des
français c'est pas de l'argent qui
m'appartient c'est de l'argent qui
appartient au français
et moi j'ai du respect pour l'argent qui
m'appartient pas et j'estime que si je
peux dépenser moins et que je peux le
rendre aux français c'est la moindre des
choses et c'est le moins de respect que
je dois à mes compatriotes
donc c'est la première raison pour
laquelle je réduis la dépense publique
c'est lorsqu'elle ne sert à rien la
seconde c'est lorsque l'état arrive en
me disant qui va réduire mes recettes et
donc par conséquent avoir moins d'argent
pour faire alors je n'aurai pas le choix
il faut que je diminue la dépense ce
sont les deux raisons
et j vous dire deux fois depuis trois
mois ce qu'on fait de façon très
concrète c'est qu'on se prend dossier
par dossier sujet par sujet et qu'on
réduit la voilure
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
très précis moi je suis chargé de
plusieurs sujets l'emploi le
développement économique le numérique la
formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage sur la formation
professionnelle
la région n'est en charge que
d'information professionnelle des
chômeurs des demandeurs d'emploi pas des
salariés les salariés c'est pas son
sujet mais il ya souvent des
organisations de salariés qui viennent
nous voir et que nous disent vous
comprenez notamment les partenaires
sociaux je pense aux syndicats vous
comprenez si vous nous aidez ça serait
vraiment bien pour le dialogue social
ah oui oui et donc un coach comme ça un
jour une organisation syndicale qui est
venu me voir et qui m'a dit vaut la
dentelle organisations professionnelles
certes qui ne forment que des salariés
vous savez traditionnellement la région
donner un peu d'argent
ah oui il donnait combien la région
d'avant elle donnait un million d'euros
ouais alors j'ai dû direct à écouter
vous ferez avec la millions d'euros en
moi et là j'ai les syndicats qui ont
regardé eux qui m'a dit vous vous rendez
compte de ce que vous faites
j bah oui j'applique le principe des
missions qui m'ont été confiées par
l'état moi je m'occupe pas de la
formation provinciale des salariés
seulement celle des chômeurs est ce que
vous faites d'informations précieuses
les chômeurs non bon ben alors au revoir
monsieur 1 millions d'euros d'économisés
ça a duré cinq minutes cinq minutes
c'est pas compliqué cinq minutes et puis
après il n'a pas rappelé mais c'est
normal
le message était clair je crois d'autres
exemples les organismes qu'on appelle
les organismes associés dans une région
c'est quoi c'est un organisme voulu
confier une mission vous lui donnez un
budget en principe il exécute la mission
que vous lui avez confié c'est très bien
sauf que parfois la mission émotions
vous lui confiez les difficiles
le problème c'est que l'organisme n'aime
pas trop la faire par exemple j'ai
découvert que pour développer le
numérique dans la région de le france
nous avions confié un budget d'un
million sept cent mille euros un
organisme pour le faire un million sept
cent mille euros
l'organisme et qui d'ailleurs était
dirigée par un ancien membre du cabinet
de du prédécesseur de valérie et donc
j'ai rien à dire ça c'est vous qui avez
ri c'est pas moi j'ai rien dit et donc
je m'informe de ce que font ces
personnes dans cet organisme est ce que
je découvre c'est que oui certes et
développe le numérique mais en fait
comme elle ils avaient un peu de temps
et un peu d'argent
ils sont livrés à des expériences
personnelles et donc par exemple j'en ai
un
c'est véridique 1 qui s'est décidé de de
se lancer dans l'invention de la voiture
mobile numérique donc par conséquent il
a dépensé l'argent de la région
donc votre argent pour construire un
prototype personnes lui avaient demandé
pour voir comment est ce que si une
voiture se déplacer on pouvait mettre
plein de fonctionnalités numérique à
l'intérieur
c'est magnifique bon ça coûtait 300
mille euros mais c'est très très bien
mais ça servait à rien et certainement
pas développer le numérique en ile de
france
bon ben j'ai divisé le budget par deux
bons et donc par conséquent n'est pas
assez d'amis en sept à huit cent mille
euros c'est normal et géré demandé à
l'organisme de rester centrée sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire à faire croître
le nombre d'entreprises de start up qui
sont liées au numérique en ile de france
voilà l'ambition de la région avec
valérie c'est ça qu'on doit faire c'est
développer l'emploi développer le
numérique développer la valeur ajoutée
et en l'occurrence je vous le dis en
avant première on fait venir avec
valérie une des plus grande
manifestation mondiale à paris à la fin
du mois de juin qui va être largement
aidé par la région et qui va attirer les
startups du monde entier pour leur dire
à quel point s'installer en ile de
france c'est utile et puis c'est
commandé un fan les c'est à dire tout le
monde est le bienvenu
ça permet de faire développer l'économie
ça permet de montrer que en france
lorsque la région est sympathique et
bien on peut venir s'installer
développer des start up développé du
savoir et développer l'économie
voyez ça c'est de l'argent utilement
dépensés pour faire en sorte de faire
grandir l'économie numérique en ile de
france plutôt que les exemples que j'ai
à vous de montrer si c'était seulement
un exemple mais ce n'est que ça à tous
les détours et voyez réduire la dépense
publique c'est facile il faut simplement
accepter le principe d' entrer dans les
détails
connaître ses dossiers travailler et
puis surtout être ferme être clair la
difficulté parfois aux hits ou du
responsable politique c'est d'être au
clair et d'être déterminée et puis de
s'y tenir
difficile de s'y tenir faut avoir de la
moelle faut avoir la détermination bon
qu'est-ce qui a su tenir pendant la
réforme des retraites
monsieur eric woerth ou sauvés comment
il a conduit la réforme des retraites en
2010 1 il n'a pas lâché la pousse
je dis pas ça un jour parce qu'il sera
premier ministre et que j'espère qu'il
prendra dans son gouvernement
quoique les blagues à part voilà un
autre qui l'a jamais si gilles carez
président de la commission des finances
combien de fois ai-je il a été
extrêmement précis sur les comptes
publics et se le faire de ne jamais
faire dériver les comptes publics et
l'état
c'est gilles et voyez chers amis la
responsabilité du politique c'est
d'avoir une ligne et de s'y tenir
d'être déterminé de ne jamais rien
lâcher et une fois qu'on s'y tient et
qu'on ne laisse rien alors là on peut
réduire la dépense publique et je peux
vous le dire avec valérie en
ile-de-france dans un an vous ne
reconnaîtrez par la région elle
dépensera mois et elle agira plus pour
vous c'est tout l'intérêt de région
piloté par la droite par les
républicains et une occurrence par
valérie
merci donc à un jérôme qui nous quitte
pour aller ratiboiser 1 million d'euros
de plus
je ne sais quelle association en tout
cas bravo ça montre une chose c'est que
nos collectivités locales de la plus
petite à la plus grande
elles ont des marges d'économies il ya
un travail à faire non pas sur la
réduction de la qualité des services aux
français mais en même temps il faut
faire l'essentiel il faut essayer de
bien le faire est une région comme ile
de france plus grandes collectivités
locales du pays le montre et c'est vrai
aussi pour la plus modeste et dans la
recherche d'économies que nous avons
chiffré dans notre document et nicolas
sarkozy les mots cra nous avons
évidemment l'idée que les collectivités
locales elles doivent contribuer à moins
de dépenses publiques
on doit pas réduire comme ça brutalement
lors dotation mais elles doivent
contribuer à moins de dépenses publiques
et nous nous aurons évidemment une
action toute particulière en lien avec
les collectivités locales sur le sujet
alors aujourd'hui c'est une réunion
laïque mais gilles et moi nous sommes
catholiques mais catholiques orthodoxes
et nous sommes aussi favorables une
forme d'orthodoxie budgétaire qui
convient bien car il n'est pas possible
au fond de continuer à redresser de
vouloir redresser le pays
si nous n'avons pas des finances
publiques qui sont en ordre et
aujourd'hui les finances publiques sont
en dix ans et les finances publiques ne
peuvent pas uniquement dépendre de
facteurs extérieurs
elles ne peuvent pas uniquement
d'étendre des taux d'intérêt et car
lorsque les finances publiques de la
france vont un peu mieux
elles vont mieux que copie au fond c'est
un peu un peu cela quand elle voit un
tout petit peu mieux
c'est essentiellement dû à des facteurs
extérieurs soit si les collectivités
locales qui ont réduit leurs dépenses
d'investissement soit ce son choix et où
est ce sont les taux d'intérêt qui au
fur et à mesure du temps en baisse on a
même des taux d'intérêt négatifs on voit
bien que l'économie perd un tout petit
peu de bon sens et qu'elle ne croit plus
en l'avenir non une bonne finances
publiques c'est une finances publiques
qui procède
qui est la conséquence d'un état d'une
structure publique qui se gère au
travers de réformes d'ordre structurel
une bonne finances publiques c'est celle
qui permet de passer des caps comme ça a
été le cas pendant la crise mais lorsque
la crise est passée revient comme le
font les allemands par exemple revient
une une insolent de public évidemment
acceptable et plus il ya de déficit
public au fonds dus à une mauvaise
raison plus évidemment et moins -
évidemment il ya d'investissement et
moyens de possibilités pour les
entreprises tout à l'heure on parlait d'
environnement amical pour les
entreprises c'est bien ça essayer de
faire en sorte de montrer que
l'entreprise n'est pas l'adversaire de
notre pays elle est au contraire
l'élément essentiel du redressement
économique de notre de notre pays donc
de bonnes finances publiques mais bonnes
finances publiques pour de bonnes
raisons c'est à dire pour des raisons de
réformes structurelles sur la dépendance
comme sur la recette sont un élément
essentiel de redressement du pays chargé
merci cher eric bonjour à toutes et à
tous justement nos finances publiques en
juin 2017
quand nous aurons gagné les élections
vont être dans une situation
catastrophique
il faut bien qu'on ait conscience que la
situation dont on va hériter n'aura rien
à voir avec celle qu'on a connue lors
des alternances précédente quand on a
succédé au socialiste en 1986 puis en
2002 comme quand on avait succédé aussi
en 1993
là nous allons être confrontés à une
situation financière radicalement
différente
il faut en avoir bien conscience d'abord
la dette publique
quand j'entre à les 100% du pib plus de
2000 milliards
bonjour à notre président
je rappelle que bonjour président je
rappelle que en 1986 la dette publique
elle était de moins de 40 % en 2002 elle
était de -2 60% 100 % en 2017
ensuite notre dépense publique elle
atteint les 50 7% du pib c'est un record
elle est très rigide
d'ailleurs il faut rappeler qu'entre
2002 et 2012 la dépense publique a
augmenté en moyenne de 35 milliards
d'euros
il faut quand même le rappeler en plus
nous aurons une situation d'overdose
fiscale totale donc aucune marge de
manoeuvre si ce n'est bien entendu que
dans le sens d'une baisse mais résolue
importante des impôts
et puis on va hériter d'un déficit
public d'un écart dépenses recettes
structurelles de l'ordre de 4 points de
pib
au moins 80 milliards d'euros et qui est
aggravée de jour en jour parce que
depuis le début de l'année sont prises
constamment des décisions de dépenses
non financées et qui se chiffrent par
milliards deux exemples point d'un 10
rue valoriser juste avant les élections
ou l'extension de la garantie de la
garantie jeunes donc des marges de
manoeuvre qui vont être réduites et
pourtant il va falloir faire ce choc
fiscal
c'est indispensable si le chiffre erika
à 25 milliards d'euros
il va falloir vraiment le faire et donc
pour moi la grande question c'est de
savoir comment on va articuler ce choc
fiscal cette baisse des prélèvements
qu'il faut faire rapidement avec des
diminutions de dépenses qui passe par
des réformes structurelles et qui met un
certain temps à produire leurs effets si
par exemple
aujourd'hui on a un équilibre sur
les caisses de retraite sur la retraite
c'est grâce à la réforme qu'à mener eric
en 2010 et aujourd'hui c'est le
gouvernement socialiste qui en touche
les dividendes en quelque sorte alors la
diminution des prélèvements bon ça a été
dit elle doit se faire en priorité sur
les entreprises mais dans l'immédiat
elle pourra pas être gagés par des
économies à la même hauteur des
économies sur les dépenses et donc nous
allons probablement pour mettre en place
ce programme devoir accepter une baisse
une aggravation du déficit public en
tout cas sur l'année 2017 2018 et donc
le risque que l'on court c'est que face
à un besoin de financement qui est
aujourd'hui le plus élevé de toute
l'europe
il nous faut 200 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui chaque année pour à la fois
couvrir le déficit
et puis remplacé la dette qui vient à
échéance face à ce besoin de financement
il faut absolument que nous continuons
de bénéficier de conditions de taux
d'intérêt et de la confiance de ceux qui
nous prêtent qui aux deux tiers sont des
non résidents et si jamais nous avions
une hausse des taux d'intérêt là nous
serions dans une situation dramatique
or il ya une modification très
importante par rapport à il ya quelques
années il ya quelques années quand la
crise a frappé
il y avait des pays fragiles l'italie
l'espagne dont les taux d'intérêt ont
progressé de 4,5 points en quelques mois
et ces pays nous ont quelque part
protéger alors que là les réformes se
font elles se font en italie elles se
font en espagne et donc notre pays qui
lui ne fait aucune réforme puisque ce
gouvernement socialiste ne fait de
réformes que des réformes qui vont
augmenter structurellement la dépense
publique
je citais l'extension de la garantie
jeunes depuis qu'on l'a créé le rmi on
avait toujours refusé d'offrir un jeune
de 18 ans
comme choix l'assistance et bien cette
digue vient d'être rompu avec la
garantie jeunes l'augmentation du point
d'indicé ou même une réforme comme la
généralisation du tiers-payant la
généralisation du tiers payant
c'est là aussi une augmentation
structurelle de dépenses publiques et
donc n'ayant fait aucune réforme
ce gouvernement n'ayant fait aucune
réforme nous met dans une situation où
l'homme malade l'homme fragile de
l'europe peut être notre pays et donc
nous devons faire très très attention
parce que une question peut se poser est
ce que l'euro continuera de nous
protéger
surtout si malheureusement le break site
devait se produire on ans dans une zone
d'instabilité et donc nous devons être
très vigilants pour garder la confiance
et pouvoir nous financer financer ce
choc fiscal dans les meilleures
conditions et donc j'en tire la
conclusion qu'il faut parallèlement
engagé décidé voter un certain nombre de
réformes structurelles pour s'assurer la
confiance
elles produiront leurs effets avec un
certain délai mais cette question
d'articulation de séquençage entre le
choc fiscal et les réformes
structurelles
elle est essentielle la réforme
structurelle on les a tous en tête
réforme des retraites
on a su faire et je salue à nouveau la
réforme vraiment excellentes qui a été
conduite en 2010 il y a évidemment la
baisse de la masse salariale rapide
la question des effectifs il ya la
réforme du marché du travail
et puis il ya une question plus
compliqué qui est la maîtrise de toutes
les dépenses sociales
aujourd'hui presque la moitié de nos
1200 milliards de dépenses publiques ce
sont des transferts sociaux et souvent
avec un fonctionnement de quiches et les
dizaines de milliards d'allocations
logement da hd médicale d'état etc etc
et là il faut absolument maîtriser ce
flux est donc pour conclure rapidement
il faut que nous soyons parfaitement
prêt sur les deux volets ils sont
complètement lié le volet de baisses
d'impôts avec une belle
de prélèvement qui va d'abord en
direction des entreprises c'est une
baisse d'ensemble j'ai pas le temps
d'évoquer ici les mesures certaines ont
été évoqués tout à l'heure et puis à
côté cela une un ensemble de vote de
réformes structurelles et ceci dans la
même dans le même laps de temps
alors du point de vue financier on aura
cette séquence le collectif de juin et
de juillet 2010 est la loi de finances
pour 2018
je pense qu'entre les deux il faudra
absolument adopter une loi de
programmation prévisionnelle qui donne
la visibilité qui donne la stip la
stabilité et qui crée un climat de
confiance confiance qui devra s'asseoir
sur ses réformes structurelles dont je
parlais et qui elle-même devront être
annoncé et même voté en même temps
autrement dit et pour conclure il ya
beaucoup de travail devant nous parce
qu'il faudra être parfaitement prêt est
prêt dans le détail pour faire passer à
la fois cet indispensable choc fiscal
mais aussi ses réformes de structures
qui nous garantiront la confiance et la
couverture de bonnes conditions des
besoins de financement
merci merci à gilles bon marqueur est
que c'est une orthodoxie mais c'est une
orthodoxie êtes une orthodoxie positive
optimiste la france peut être redressée
moins de dépenses publiques
fall chiffrer aujourd'hui les gens
attendent de nous confie chiffres les
choses vous attendent de nous des choses
précises mais ils attendent aussi un cap
une vision
il faut dire pourquoi on veut faire ça
et on veut faire ça moins de dépenses
moins d'impôts pour redresser notre pays
notre pays en a bien besoin et nicolas
sarkozy maintenant va nous en parler